the classic 1988 film Beetlejuice was
never intended to cater to very young
audiences but it wiggled its way into
their awareness like a sandworm in the
desert
if you loved Beetlejuice as a kid and
haven't revisited it in a while here are
some things that just might surprise you
when Adam and Barbara Maitland
discovered that they are ghosts and that
newcomers have bought their home they
travel to the land of the dead in an
attempt to get some assistance before
they can see any one about getting help
they have to take a number and a seat in
an afterlife waiting room at the end of
the movie viewers see Beetlejuice in the
same room stuck with a terminally long
wait this scene plays on the joke of
waiting rooms everywhere which many
young viewers might not have a lot of
experience with but that's not the most
adult element of the sequence it also
showcases a parade of victims of various
deaths that only a very twisted child
would immediately grasp there's a
magician's assistant who has been cut in
two and a jungle explorer with a
shrunken head sitting right next to Adam
is a man who looks like he's been burned
to a crisp you want a cigarette
thank you trying to cut down myself
while these dead characters are intended
to be amusing it's probably for the best
that young viewers don't really
understand how gruesome or horrible
their deaths were Lydia dietz's
stepmother Delia is a high-class high
maintenance sculptor from New York
despite objections from her husband
Charles a former real estate developer
she seeks to transform their cozy
Connecticut home into a modern upscale
abode with the help of an interior
designer named Otho the two dig into
their new project with nothing but
disdain for the charming house they're
about to destroy oh look an indoor
outhouse understandably this is
heartbreaking for Adam and Barbara since
they'll never get to grow old in the
house they worked so hard to make their
own Connecticut is notorious for having
high-end property that's purchased by
the rich and famous for example rapper
50 cent recently sold his Connecticut
mansion for 2.9 million dollars in
Beetlejuice director Tim Burton pokes
fun at the wealthy invaders from out of
state who blessed her into a sleepy town
and drive up the property value this
type of reference requires a working
knowledge of social politics and real
estate anxieties in order to really
appreciate it something that most young
viewers won't readily understand
perfectly portrayed by Michael Keaton
the character of Beetlejuice is a lot in
every sense of the word he's loud he's
brash he's completely over the top most
of the things he says in his used car
salesman patter
requires some solid pop-culture
background he claims that the Exorcist
keeps getting funnier every time he sees
it but hopefully young viewers haven't
seen that movie yet he also shouts go
ahead make my millennium and a clear
reference to the Dirty Harry movie set
an impact another film that most kids
probably wouldn't be too familiar with
and of course throughout the entire
movie Beetlejuice is a completely
unapologetic perv excuse me he's the
kind of ghost you definitely don't want
hanging around your teenage daughter or
your teenage son for that matter this is
played for laughs but adult viewers will
be creeped out by his treatment of Lydia
forcing her into a marriage and
reference
his intentions for their wedding night
basically Beetlejuice is the least
kid-friendly part of beetlejuice though
the name beetlejuice sounds
appropriately sinister for the movie's
main man it's also the name of a star in
the constellation Orion some
translations of the name which comes
from Arabic indicate that it means
armpit of Orion which kind of makes
sense for a guy with such questionable
personal hygiene otherwise the use of a
star's name and the actual sound of it
lends to a kind of mystical magical
witchy element to a character who is
decidedly none of those things though
Lydia and her fascination with the dead
might qualify as sufficiently witchy
this is one of those little factoids
that adults with an eye for the skies
would probably recognize long before
their younger counterparts when a
special effect is done well hopefully
the audience doesn't even notice it
certainly kids who are already prone to
suspending their disbelief are willing
to accept bizarre visuals without
question and the visuals in this film
along with everything else
our bizarre in the best possible way
from the Maitland's stretched out faces
to shrimp cocktails attacking dinner
guests the effects crew on this film did
an incredible job Beetlejuice even won
the Academy Award for Best makeup in
1989 a tribute not only to Keaton's
unrecognizable message but also the
imaginative visual treatment of the
Maitland's and all the inhabitants of
the waiting room any adult who remembers
a time before CGI can appreciate all the
practical effects in stop-motion that
went into this classic film Winona Ryder
has come back in a big way with her role
as Joyce buyers and Netflix's stranger
things to this end
some young viewers might not realize
that she's been a major star for decades
her stranger things co-star priya
ferguson admits that she didn't know who
ryder was before she met her on set but
older fans will know that Beetlejuice
provided writer with her breakthrough
role which would lead her to a very
successful in diverse screen career
Ryder was only 17 years old when she
played Lydia who was supposed to be even
younger but there was something about
the actress that absolutely clicked with
her character I myself am strange and
unusual the year after Beetlejuice was
released she's
in heathers further cementing her status
as a rising young star possessing the
gift of hindsight adult viewers of
beetlejuice today can probably see
writers acting trajectory in ways that
younger audiences might not appreciate
most kids today would never guess that
the fun-loving Beetlejuice and the
crime-fighting Batman were both
portrayed by the same actor Michael
Keaton completely caked in makeup and
spouting euphemisms Keaton's beetlejuice
has more in common with Gotham's
infamous Joker than its Dark Knight but
just one year after Beetlejuice Keaton
brooded his way through 1989 s Batman
and nailed the serious nature of both
Bruce Wayne and the Caped Crusader it's
also hard to say if young viewers would
easily recognize him as vulture in
spider-man homecoming with a range that
stretches from whacky physical comedy
that thoughtful action films and
everything in between
nobody should be surprised that Keaton
has had such a long and acclaimed career
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
classic movies are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]